how can you ask better questions like if
you want better Solutions you have to
learn how to ask better questions for me
it was always you pay attention and if
it's not working then you say why is it
not working you essentially start with a
question and it's one of the reasons why
I have some problem with mission
statements the problem with a lot of
mission statements is that it actually
is starting with an answer that doesn't
generate new discussion we never had
anything like our goal is to make the
best films like that I'd rather be in a
position where people say well what are
we doing here what is our goal every
time they ask that question then they're
thinking about it and it's fluid it's
fluid it should always be fluid because
the world is fluid